in the darkest time for our country for
the whole europe i call on you to do
more new packages of sanctions are
needed constantly every week until the
russian military machine stops
restrictions are needed for everyone on
whom this unjust regime is based
we propose that the united states
sanctions
all politicians in the russian
federation who remain in their offices
and do not
cut ties with those who are responsible
for the aggression against ukraine from
state dumas members to the last official
who has lack of morale to break the
state terror all americans company
must leave russia from their market
leave their market
immediately because it is flooded with
our blunt
ladies and gentlemen members of congress
please take the lead if you have
companies in your districts who
finance the russian military machine
leaving business in russia you should
put pressure i'm asking to make sure
that the russians do not receive a
single penny that they use to destroy
people in ukraine
the destruction of our country the
destruction of europe all american ports
should be closed for uh russian
goods
we um
peace is more important than income and
we have to defend this principle in the
whole world the war of the past have
prompted our predecessors to create
institutions
that should protect us from war
but
they unfortunately don't work we see it
you see it so we need new ones new
institutions new alliances and we offer
them we propose to create an association
you 24 united for peace a union of
responsible countries
that have the strength and consciousness
to stop conflicts immediately provide
all the necessary assistance in 24 hours
if necessary even weapons if necessary
sanctions humanitarian support political
support finances everything you need to
keep
the peace and quickly